moi personnellement c'est pas à bigard
que gens veulent plus c'est aux gens qui
tirent les ficelles derrière parce que
la lan et bigard ils ont aucune pensée
scientifique épidémiologie arrière
derrière c'est évidemment alexandra
aurions codes ses nuits c'est là la
femme l'ancien l'ancien ce scientifique
qui est à côté de bigard lors de la
cérémonie et qui les excite tous elle
elle tient des propos qui sont des pour
peau ultra complotistes mais elle n'a su
le jeu personne est derrière elle elle
organise donc des réunions avec la lan
et bigard est derrière bigard voilà
voilà alexandra aurions code est
derrière vous avez bigard qui est qui
qui va au feu qui est son porte flingues
et c'est absolument scandaleux avec
s'est trouvé au langon avec son c'est
inacceptable d'expliquer qu'il faut
qu'un ministre crève d'expliquer que
c'est un assassin alors qu'il se bat
contre une maladie qu'on connaît encore
pas très bien c'est juste honteux
ces gens sont des complotistes fous ces
gens sont des complotistes délirant et
il faut faire attention parce que de
derrière des tels mots de démo aussi
terrible il pourrait y avoir quelqu'un
qui prend un flingue et qui va tuer les
ministres nous c'est à dire que derrière
cette violence des rebelles pourrait
avoir du sens politique
il ya 40 ans il ya 40 ans en france il
fout on assassiner le patron de renault
oui à prendre assassiné en italie des
grands patrons
on a assassiné le premier ministre itri
l'italien et on a assassiné en allemagne
le patron des patrons le le patron du
patronat donc la violence politique elle
peut revenir quand vous avez quelqu'un
comme bigard qui est adoré notamment par
les gilets jaunes qui explique que vers
ans doit crever comme buzek s'est des
assassins eh bien il ya quelqu'un qui
peut prendre un flingue et à les tuer
ses ministres et donc c'est extrêmement
dangereux pour ne doit pas jouer avec la
violence politique
elle arrive suffisamment vite la
violence politique pour que des abrutis
comme ça ne soit pas laissée seule avec
des mots qui peuvent tuer parce que les
mots de cet abruti peuvent tuer expliqué
que le ministre doit crever c'est une
incitation à l'est le foot une balle
entre les deux yeux
il ya suffisamment de cinglé dans les
rues pour pas les exciter un peu plus
donc bigard il faut le boycotter il faut
absolument ne plus l'écouter
et il faut que les gens raisonnables qui
sont autour de lui les m'explique qui
déconne à à plein tube et que c'est
inacceptable ce qu'il fait parce que
c'est inacceptable d'un point de vue
moral et politique alors richard beaudry
vous étiez à présent la manif qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça ce que vous étiez
alors vous savez sur marie et je le dis
c'est vraiment un ami c'est mon ami ici
on voit là et j'ai jeu là là dessus je
trouve ça et voilà j'ai vu les propos
c'est vrai que c'est excessif au niveau
des propos c'est une vrai que ces voiles
à ccc que c'est compliqué de devecser
voilà c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
s'est fait influencer
j'ai un peu d'accord avec monsieur
alexandre se trouve que là dessus c'est
influencé que là il a été trop loin là
dessus et après sur ces sur ses thèses
voilà il pense ce qu'il veut
chacun pour ceux qui ne et c'est vrai
que moi il m'arrive très souvent de ne
pas être d'accord avec son mari sans
reste néanmoins amis mais là c'est vrai
que c'est assez violent
et quand tu crèves c'est c'est quand
même il ya le ghana et wigan
l'incitation au meurtre
c'est violent qu'est ce que jean-marie
on voit la ccc il est comme ça il est
mais je pense qu'ils en pensent
il pense pas un mot de ce qu'il dit là
j'ai trois choses à dire à d'abord les
assassins ce ton ce sont eux les
assassins ceux qui depuis un an et demi
nous foutons des prisons joue avec nos
nerfs joue avec nous jouët nos enfants
qui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui veulent faire vacciner nos
enfants si aujourd'hui nous fout des
masques à longueur de journée qui
aujourd'hui nous emprisonne si
aujourd'hui nous empêche de vivre en
paix aujourd'hui nous empêche de voir
nos grands parents c'est aujourd'hui
nous empêche de vivre notre propre vie
j'ai cinq enfants
j'ai déjà il y en a deux qui sont ici
dans les dents dans les coulisses de ces
gosses ne peuvent pas vivre depuis un an
et demi vous trouvez ça normal en raison
de quoi en raison de quoi dit que moi
alors elle n'aime pas en mémoire le taux
de mortalité est un film ici gilles est
un film sont mortes et l'été on le sait
mais sharon est dans une dictature
aujourd'hui
d'accord j'étais présentateurs on
s'achète de gt présentateur et vous le
savez sur france télévisions je
présentais le soir 3 j'ai toujours été
super bien noté personnel tu as dit que
je délirais dans ma vie mais c'est vrai
alexandre alors aurions qu il se permet
de dire cette espèce de crétin en face
de moi
il espère maintenir qui sait cette femme
c'est la généticienne numéro un qui est
aussi un air frais si tous ces mares
salines
il est pas du tout elle et elle est
envoyée par qui a beaucoup car son chef
de paris au port
et si cette année il y aura plus accord
oui donc venez vous essayer
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire dans
votre vidéo d'enfance à le quitter
l'epic est honnête sincère qu'on envoie
à l'abattoir mais c'est scandaleux ce
que vous faites vous êtes de complotiste
de conspirationnistes d'abord un
journaliste il doit douter de ce que les
gouvernements n'étant plus jeunes outre
été blanche et ont deux à ça je vais
vous dire un truc me l'avait pas nous
traiter de me demander si vous voulez on
lui a demandé s'il voulait faire
vacciner ses enfants et d'être dit non
j'ai vu ça juste avant de venir vous
n'avez aucun droit de nous traiter
d'abord je voudrais pas du tout dans le
même sens menée correctement ok si vous
ne prenez aucun de respect pour bull la
terrasse artificielle garder là pour
vous vous allez allez pourquoi vous
vivez en belgique aujourd'hui c'est pour
vous un obus est là bas avec le mans on
faisait surtout les plateaux ici vous
allez au magic en cours sont plus
souples elles auront c'est scandaleux
pendant